this is so cool whoa I mean whoa
that's right Alan is a real-life Jedi
maker with his video racking up over
eight and a half million views online
how does his trailblazing sword work fit
this lightsaber Alan's decide not to use
light but to use fire inside Alan's
off-the-shelf lightsaber shell there's a
canister with a moveable syringe like
plunger inside it above the plunger is
the fuel and below it is liquid butane
which at normal room temperature should
be a gas
this means it's trying to expand pushing
up the plunger and the fuel above it is
under incredible pressure when Alan
pushes a button if you'll come shout for
a tiny syringe he'll the diameter of the
hole is just the thickness of two sheets
of paper and because the liquid fuel is
incompressible the smaller the hole is
the faster it'll come out which means it
goes really fast and gives them the
length of flame that we see here it's
kind of like when you have a garden hose
and you put your thumb over the end of
it it creates a jet which makes the
water shoot further as the fuel leaves
the handle he lights the stream at the
press of a button and the whole stream
ignites a real master rally nurse try
this not at home
Oh